so when people compare the American
government with the Chinese government
they say this is a comparison within a
democratic system and an authoritarian
system and a democratic system is of
course better than Authority and system
and I agree a democratic system is
better than an authoritarian system but
if you go if you dig one level down and
you look at the functioning of the
government and how it makes its
decisions and you analyze it you may see
that the democratic system may be
performing as a plutocratic system
serving the interests of the people the
tiny elite and leaving thus creating a
situation where I think half your
population hasn't seen an increase in
his median income for 40 years
that's what plutocracy is the Chinese
system is a meritocracy now the Chinese
Communist Party is not perfect it has a
lot of flaws in making lot of mistakes
by in terms of harvesting the brainpower
of China it has done an amazing job and
I tell the story you know I was in
diplomacy for 33 years when I started my
career in 1971 if you had asked me do
you want to talk to an American diplomat
or Chinese diplomat I would say of
course and talk to an American diplomat
is graduate of Princeton Yale Harvard
brilliant reads The New Yorker every
week knows what's going on the world a
Chinese diplomat 1971 would walk around
with a mouse to the red book in his
pocket and when I talk to him you'll
produce mouse read book and read to me
or Mouse read book why should I waste my
time Chinese that's empty one you fast
forward to 2018 and you ask me to fly to
a capital somewhere and you said you
want to talk to the American ambassador
or the Chinese ambassador the likelihood
is that the China
ambassador would speak the language of
the country would have been posted there
several times would have a very new and
sophisticated view of the country and
the American ambassador would be one
who's demoralized knowing that his
budget is being cut knowing his chances
of becoming an ambassador and the top
capital is practically zero because
there are political appointees so you
have a demoralized the American
diplomatic service and an incredibly
dynamic Chinese Foreign Service that's
what that's a big change that has
happened since 1971 and that's a result
of meritocracy